- La tradition malgache dit
qu'aux enterrements, on chante.
Ce matin, le village porte
une enfant vers son tombeau.
Le rite dure la journée entière
et réunit tous les habitants des environs.
C'est Marcel, un ancien,
qui nous parle de la cérémonie.
La tradition indique qu'à chaque fois
que l'un des nôtres meurt,
on doit tuer un zébu
pour honorer son départ.
La petite fille qui est morte,
j'étais son grand-père.
Les hommes forts du village
s'occupent de la bête.
Le sacrifice du zébu
est rare, précieux.
Il permet de ressouder le clan
au cours de l'épreuve.
- C'est comme un échange.
Le ciel nous prend un mort,
nous prenons un zébu.
Le lien, c'est le sang.
Le sang des hommes
contre le sang des zébus.
La viande du zébu est immédiatement
partagée entre tous les convives.
- Tiens, prends l'argent.
Les contributions de chacun
sont répertoriées dans ce grand cahier,
car le prix d'une bête équivaut ici,
à une année de salaire.
Pour ma tribu,
le zébu c'est sacré.
Le zébu, c'est une richesse.
C'est comme notre propre enfant.
Au sud de Madagascar, plus qu'ailleurs,
le destin des hommes est lié
à celui de leur seule richesse,
le zébu.
Car ici ce bovin sert à tout.
C'est un moyen de locomotion très commode.
Il sert à labourer les rizières.
Et au paysan, il fournit aussi l'engrais.
Premiers signes extérieurs de richesse,
le zébu déchaîne les convoitises.
Depuis toujours, les voleurs s'en emparent
dans l'immensité des pâturages.
Mais ces derniers temps, le phénomène
de vol de zébu a pris une ampleur inédite.
30 à 40000 têtes de bétail
disparaissent chaque année.
Ces vols de masse déstabilisent
des régions entières de l'île.
C'est au sud qu'agissent les voleurs,
hors des sentiers battus,
à l'intérieur des terres,
notre destination.
Le voyage commence dans un taxi brousse,
bien serré,
aux côtés d'une famille malgache
en plein déménagement.
Ça secoue un peu et ça tangue.
Mais cette fois, ça passe.
Enfin, quelques mètres plus loin,
c'est l'inévitable panne moteur.
Salut, ça va?
À l'intérieur, ça cause non pas de mécanique,
mais de la vraie peur du moment.
Ces voleurs de zébus
qu'on appelle ici les dahalos.
- Quand les Dahalos débarquent, ils crient,
ils utilisent des sifflets.
Ils tirent partout.
Je me suis cachée, mais j'avais peur
qu'ils me repèrent.
- Les boutiques ferment
les unes après les autres.
- Tout le monde s'en va.
- Les instituteurs, même les médecins,
tout le monde s'enfuit.
Il nous faudra encore 2 jours de piste,
pour parvenir dans un des territoires
les plus reculés de Madagascar.
Ces vastes landes au sud-est de l'île.
Ici, il n'existe qu'un seul moyen
de communication,
c'est de remonter cette rivière.
Nous pénétrons maintenant sur le territoire
des voleurs de zébu.
L'étrange sensation de ne pas être
les bienvenus, d'être épié.
Nous ne sommes pas très rassurés,
d'ailleurs, notre piroguier non plus.
- Les dahalos, ce sont des violents.
Ils frappent.
Ils sont sans pitié.
Ils ne pensent qu'à tuer.
J'ai peur de venir ici, mais
je n'ai pas le choix, c'est ma région.
Je ne peux pas faire autrement.
Sur cette rivière,
chaque rencontre est déstabilisantes.
Qui sont les voleurs de zébu ?
Comment les distinguer
des simples habitants ?
La légende des dahalos parcourt le pays,
mais la plupart du temps,
ils restent invisibles.
Ils n'apparaissent
que pour des attaques éclairs.
Un des chefs de bande a finalement
accepté de nous rencontrer.
Méfiant, il nous donne rendez-vous
hors de sa forêt.
Nous attendions un adulte,
première surprise,
il a l'allure d'un enfant.
Ravak n'a que seize ans.
- Dans la bande que je dirige,
on est 50 dahalos.
On est tous pareils.
On est tous des jeunes.
On a 16, 17, 18 ans maximum.
Les derniers vols de zébu,
ça varie selon les fois.
On a pris 50 bêtes, 80 bêtes.
Et le plus gros coup qu'on ait fait,
c'est 100 zébus en une seule fois.
Ce qu'il faut comprendre, c'est que
c'est nous qui prenons tous les risques.
Mais des intermédiaires nous les achètent
beaucoup moins cher que leur valeur.
Ils les achètent à peine à moitié prix.
Et nous, dans la forêt,
on n'a que des racines de manioc à manger.
On ne peut rien cultiver, on ne peut même
pas manger du riz comme tout le monde.
Ou alors, on doit voler pour manger.
Je vous le dis, on souffre.
Les motivations premières de Ravak,
c'est le désir de revanche,
la vengeance et l'extrême pauvreté.
Si je suis devenu Dahalo, c'est que
mon père a été tué par d'autres dahalos,
qui ont volé son troupeau.
Je n'avais plus rien.
J'ai dû quitter le village
pour dormir dans la forêt.
À la tête de sa bande de Dahalos,
Malgré son jeune âge,
Ravak a franchi toutes les limites.
Il ne renie rien.
- La dernière fois que j'ai tué quelqu'un ?
Ça fait longtemps.
Au moins trois lunes.
J'en ai tué un par ici.
J'en ai aussi tué par là-bas.
Des crimes qui alimentent la légende
des dahalos du Grand Sud.
Avec sa désinvolture, Ravak et sa horde
terrorisent une région entière.
Ces adolescents volent en priorité
les gros propriétaires comme Edmond.
Depuis maintenant trois mois,
l'éleveur ne quitte plus
sa vieille carabine russe.
- Je vous le dis, moi, je suis plus
tranquille quand je marche avec mon fusil.
On ne peut jamais être sûr de rien.
Les dahalos peuvent être dans le coin.
Edmond était un homme respecté,
le plus gros éleveur du village.
Son troupeau comptait trois fois plus
de têtes que celui-là,
300 zébus au total.
Jusqu'à un certain jour de cet été.
- Les voleurs sont arrivés
vers 5 h du matin.
Mon fils rentrait à la maison
après avoir gardé les zébus.
Et là, les Dahalos ont débarqué.
Ils se sont mis à tirer des coups de feu.
Oui, ça s'est passé comme ça.
Sans aucune assistance, Edmond s'est tout
de suite lancé avec des hommes du village,
à la poursuite des dahalos.
Il y a perdu bien plus que son troupeau.
- Pendant deux jours jusqu'aux
montagnes qui se trouvent loin là-bas,
moi et un groupe de villageois, on a tenté
de rattraper le groupe de voleurs de zébu,
mais les Dahalos ont tué neuf hommes.
Neuf morts parmi les nôtres
pendant la poursuite.
Quand j'ai vu tous ces morts
parmi les villageois,
et moi qui suis resté en vie, je me suis
dit que ça n'en vaut pas la peine.
On ne vit qu'une fois.
À Madagascar, on dit que les zébus sont
la banque de l'éleveur, son patrimoine.
Le troupeau d'Edmond volé,
c'est l'héritage de 10 générations
qui disparaît.
Au village, Edmond avait imaginé
un grand avenir pour ses enfants.
Ses filles ont fait des études.
Elles devaient même un jour
partir en ville.
Quant à son fils aîné, il ne lui reste
que sa force et son sourire.
- L'État ne peut rien pour nous.
Ils ne nous rendront jamais
notre troupeau de zébu.
On n'a plus rien et on va devoir
tout recommencer à zéro.
On ne te respecte pas ici
si tu n'as pas de zébu.
Si tu commences à avoir des zébus,
là on te respecte.
Avant, j'avais un grand troupeau,
j'étais un homme considéré.
Maintenant qu'on m'a tout volé,
les gens ne m'écoutent plus,
ils ne me regardent plus de la même façon,
j'ai perdu leur estime.
Pour les familles comme celle d'Edmond,
très nombreuses à Madagascar,
L'État n'a pas prévu de dédommagement.
Mais une grande bataille.
La guerre contre les voleurs de zébu.
Elle est menée par des militaires
dont nous suivons un détachement.
Au total, ils sont 1000
à travers toute l'île.
Et déjà sur la route, un peloton de gendarmes
exhibe fièrement une première prise.
6 enfants, il s'agirait de Dahalos.
Ils ont 14, 15, 16 ans,
tous marqués par l'arrestation.
L'un d'entre eux porte le même foulard
rouge et les amulettes que Ravak,
le chef voleur que nous avions rencontré.
- Je ne sais pas pourquoi ils m'ont arrêté.
Je crois que c'est juste
parce que j'avais ces grigris.
Ils ne m'ont pas attrapé
dans la forêt mais au village.
Mais je ne suis pas Dahalo.
- Arrête de mentir !
En ces temps d'opérations antivoleurs
de zébu,
le grigri vaut d'abord
comme une preuve à charge.
Mais qu'il soit simple berger ou vrai dahalo,
tous ici croient à la magie
et aux vertus de ces amulettes.
- Ils mettent toutes sortes de choses
à l'intérieur des grigris.
Et ça leur permet de se protéger
des balles et de les éviter.
Celui-là,
il l'utilise pour se rendre invisible.
Ces deux là, se ressemblent,
elles servent à éviter la fatigue.
Selon moi, c'est clair,
ce gars là est un dahalo,
Un voleur de zébu.
C'est pour ça qu'ils mettent
le foulard et l'amulette.
Ultime preuve brandie par les gendarmes,
un fusil fait maison
retrouvé chez un suspect.
C'est l'arme utilisée
par les dahalos, les bandits.
Ils arrivent dans le village,
ils font les pillages,
ils enlèvent tous les bétails
et actuellement,
ils ont essayé de voler aussi
des marmites et des matelas,
et tout ce qui se trouve dans la maison.
Et après, ils les amènent
dans la forêt.
Bien escorté, le camion de gendarmes part
déposer les 6 adolescents au pénitencier.
Ces suspects risquent 5 à 10 ans de prison.
Dirigé par le capitaine Rodhain,
les militaires ont pour mission de sécuriser
un village d'une zone très reculée.
Ils pénètrent dans la forêt primaire
où ils risquent une embuscade,
des gamins voleurs de zébu.
- La consigne, c'est une distance
de cinq mètres entre chaque homme.
Préparez vos armes,
vous rechargez maintenant.
C'est bon ?
C'est dans cette même jungle que
les dahalos cachent leurs zébus volés,
et préparent leurs attaques.
Sortie du labyrinthe tropical
après plus de 50 kilomètres,
les soldats arrivent épuisés
au village de Lavarat.
Pour faire leur caserne provisoire,
ils ont réquisitionné l'école du village.
Ici, la présence des militaires rassure.
Depuis qu'ils sont là,
les dahalos n'attaquent plus.
Mais à peine arrivés,
un problème majeur resurgit.
L'opération antivoleurs de zébu a commencé
il y a trois mois,
et les militaires n'ont jamais été payés.
Au tableau noir, ils reprennent
leurs réflexes d'écolier.
Additions, multiplications,
les chiffres sont astronomiques.
- Ça, c'est l'argent qu'on nous doit.
Nous, on cherche juste à être payés,
à être tranquilles.
Mais si on n'est pas payé aujourd'hui,
on part.
On s'en fout, on rentre à la maison.
Il y en a marre ! Maintenant il faut
qu'on aille voir les chefs,
ce n'est plus possible, on n'a rien à manger !
Le capitaine Rodhain sera trouver les quelques
rares billets pour éviter la mutinerie.
Devant notre caméra, les militaires
repartent du bon pied,
pour suivre la piste
d'un troupeau de zébu volé.
Les dahalos, les voleurs agissent,
dans l'immensité des plateaux et forêts.
Ils ont toujours un temps d'avance
sur les soldats.
Sans hélico, sans voitures, sans motos,
les militaires enquêtent à pied
dans les petits hameaux du coin.
- Bonjour, comment ça va ici ?
- Et la sécurité dans le village, ça va ?
- Oui, ça va.
Cette toute petite communauté
est encore traumatisée.
Récemment, ils ont assisté au plus
gros vol de zébu de la région.
- Vous savez, ce vol de 400 zébus,
juste à côté de notre village,
les militaires n'ont jamais
retrouvé les bêtes. Pas un seul zébu.
Dans ce coin de brousse, encore une fois,
l'armée arrive trop tard.
Alors le chef du village a bien
une petite mission pour les militaires.
Débarrasser la rivière voisine d'un crocodile
qui a dévoré un habitant.
Les soldats se prennent au jeu,
l'occasion de sortir leur kalachnikov
et de faire enfin,
une démonstration de leur force.
- Un seul coup, pas plus.
Attention, les gars.
Visez bien.
Vous tirez qu'une seule balle.
- Cessez le feu ! Qui est le fou
qui a tiré complètement à gauche ?
Bouba, qu'est-ce que tu as fait ?
C'est toi qui as tiré en premier ?
Les gars, vous êtes nuls !
Le caïman avait déjà plongé,
et vous avez continué à tirer dans l'eau.
- Moi, j'étais juste à côté
et j'ai entendu les tirs !
- Punition générale !
Trois jours de corvée !
Une bonne rigolade et une photo souvenir.
Image trompeuse d'une armée détendue.
Ailleurs, dans de nombreuses régions,
les militaires,
sont soupçonnés d'être à l'origine
de graves incidents.
- Beaucoup de médias évoquent
des bavures graves,
dans l'opération antivoleurs de zébu.
Est-ce que vous pensez que c'est vrai ?
- C'est faux. C'est complètement faux,
parce que dans notre ordre de mission,
tout est détaillé très précisément.
Notre mission, ce n'est pas
de tuer les Dahalos.
L'important, c'est uniquement
de récupérer les troupeaux de zébus.
Mais à 200 kilomètres à l'ouest d'ici,
voleurs de zébu et militaires,
se sont affrontés au cours
d'un accrochage sanglant.
Cette fois, des soldats sont morts.
Sur l'île, l'affaire fait grand bruit.
- Embuscades à Ankazoabo Sud,
les dahalos sont des ennemis de la nation.
Nous considérons dorénavant les dahalos
comme des ennemis de la nation.
Telle est la déclaration
du général Béni Xavier,
chef d'état major de l'armée malgache,
en réaction à l'embuscade
tendue en Ankazoabo Sud,
et laquelle s'est soldée par huit morts
dans les rangs des militaires.
Huit morts côté militaire,
40 présumés Dahalos tués le même jour.
Depuis, c'est l'escalade de la violence.
Les représentants des droits de l'homme
reçoivent des plaintes par dizaines,
pour dénoncer les exactions de l'armée.
- Pourquoi les droits de l'homme
ne sont pas respectés ?
L'une des plaintes qu'on a reçues,
c'est qu'il y a des militaires qui tuent,
sans même enquêter sur les personnes
qui soi-disant,
étaient responsables du vol des zébus.
Que se passe-t-il au juste
dans le Sud-Ouest de Madagascar ?
Nous voici à Ankazoabo.
À priori, une petite ville de campagne
à l'allure tranquille.
Mais ici, chaque semaine, la guerre
des zébus entraîne de nouvelles bavures.
À l'hôpital de la ville, Christian
est venu voir son petit frère.
C'est un jeune berger qui a rencontré
une armée sur les nerfs.
Ce matin là, je suis allé tôt
à l'étable pour voir les zébus.
Comme tous les jours.
J'ai entendu des gens crier : "Dahalos !"
J'ai cru que des voleurs arrivaient,
alors j'ai pris mon arme et je suis sorti.
En fait, c'étaient des militaires.
Ils m'ont dit : "Jette ton arme !"
C'est ce que j'ai fait mais après ça,
ils m'ont quand même tiré dessus.
J'ai pris une balle dans la main,
là, juste ici.
Et l'autre, je l'ai prise dans la jambe.
J'espère que je vais m'en sortir.
Mais à Ankazoabo, on nous dit
que l'armée aurait fait bien pire,
que de blesser un enfant.
C'est dans les petits villages aux alentours
que les militaires ont frappé le plus durement.
Farah a 18 ans.
Elle cherche en vain un vestige
dans les décombres de sa maison.
- Il ne reste plus rien de la maison.
Les militaires ont tout brûlé et volé.
tout ce qui avait de la valeur.
Nous découvrons un village entier
que les militaires viennent d'incendier.
Une expédition punitive sans enquête,
sur la seule foi d'une dénonciation.
Les soldats avaient une liste
de noms de supposés Dahalos,
tous membres de la famille de Farah.
- Les militaires étaient nombreux.
Ils sont passés par là.
Ils ont ordonné à mon frère,
mon neveu et mon cousin,
de s'asseoir contre ce mur.
Alors, pour être sûrs,
les militaires ont dit :.
"C'est quoi le nom du village ?"
C'est Ampefy.
Puis ils ont demandé les noms.
Les gens ont donné leurs noms.
Alors les militaires se sont mis à tirer.
Mon neveu a pris une balle dans la poitrine.
Mon frère a pris une première balle
dans la cuisse,
puis lui ont tiré dans le bassin,
et une dernière dans la tête.
Les deux sont morts.
Mon cousin s'est évanoui.
Ils ne l'ont pas tué.
Après, les militaires se sont mis
à brûler les maisons, une par une.
Tout le village.
Accusé d'avoir volé des zébus,
le frère de Farah,
avait pourtant été disculpé
au tribunal et reconnu innocent.
Mais le soupçon et la volonté de revanche
de l'armée l'ont emporté.
- Je suis triste et en colère.
En tuant mon frère,
les militaires ont tué un innocent.
Il n'était pas Dahalos.
C'est lui qui nous nourrissait,
moi et les enfants.
Nous n'avons plus rien
pour vivre maintenant.
Dans ce village calciné, écrasé de soleil,
le dernier refuge, c'est le grand manguier
et son ombre protectrice.
Les habitants s'y sont réfugiés
autour de leur chef.
- Maintenant, à chaque fois
qu'on entend un bruit de moteur,
on se dit que ça peut être les militaires.
Alors on préfère fuir dans la forêt.
Vous savez, avant,
notre village prenait de l'ampleur.
C'était un beau village.
On allait même y installer un marché.
Des populations brisées,
livrées à elles-mêmes.
Ici, la violence de l'État est aussi
aveugle que celle des bandits.
Partout, le manque de moyens amplifie
les erreurs de jugement.
La distance, freine sans cesse la vérité,
et fait grandir la légende des dahalos,
les voleurs de zébus de Madagascar.